hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión
vamos a abordar las denominadas terapias
de conversión y es que a lo largo de
todo el mundo siguen existiendo iglesias
entidades y también organizaciones
dedicadas a curar la homosexualidad esto
por supuesto entre comillas y es por eso
que nos acompaña a robert moreno víctima
y sobreviviente de este tipo de
prácticas que visibilizan de alguna
manera lo que son las violencias que
sigue sufriendo el colectivo el eje
bético más robert moore era muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24
buenas tardes a todos hasta santiago
bueno roberts muchísimas gracias
nuevamente naciste en un contexto
familiar particular fuertemente
atravesado por la religión verdad bueno
por supuesto además que cada hogar cada
crianza nos determina nos marca a todos
pero en tu caso te llevo por un camino
de enormes padecimientos verdad antes de
que llegaran a este tipo de prácticas de
las que fuiste víctima cómo era tu vida
rubén cómo te sentías con tu ser con tu
identidad con tu homosexualidad
pues
y yo sea creciera familia evangélica
protestante cosa cristiana y pues
siempre todos los típicos los domingos
que llevan a la iglesia vas creciendo te
vas dando cuenta que eres un poco
diferente con los demás niños o sea que
los padres te inculcan las cosas
diferentes
y ya cuando llegas a la adolescencia y
te das cuenta de que eres mi caso
homosexual
pues para ser un bache muy muy
complicado deciros que hay ahora acabó
con mi vida además soy del año 88 que
tampoco había tanta información como lo
hay ahora entonces no sé pensabas que
ser homosexual era algo horrible que era
malísimo entonces no quería
tener ese estilo de vida también por la
decepción que podría causar a mi familia
ahora en ese contexto rubén lo que fue
tu salida del closet por usar un término
no popularmente conocido para lo que es
no ocultar la identidad propia no a
partir de una perdón una salida del
closet que en tu caso fue forzada a la
fuerza no a partir de allí apareció lo
que fue tu primer contacto con este tipo
de práctica habrá un exorcismo en
particular que sucedió así y rubén
efe
resulta de que yo bueno yo soy de españa
y siempre hablaba con chicos de
latinoamérica normalmente porque me daba
miedo de que casualmente habláramos de
españa que coincidiera con con mi
iglesia o con gente conocida o algo
entonces hablaba con un chico que era de
colombia y me dejé una parte del
messenger de aquel entonces una parte
abierta de la conversación que decía si
mi familia se entera que soy gay me
muero y lo leyó mi hermana mi hermana lo
comunicó a mis padres me hicieron una
encerrona del comedor de casa me dijeron
ven tenemos que hablar y ya pues
desastres
es un desastre
familias y para quieras homosexual rubén
sí
o sea es
entonces tenía miedo o sea yo nunca está
preparado para delante de mi familia
salir del closet nunca está preparado
absolutamente ahora después llegaste a
lo que fue una terapia de conversión en
brasil en una iglesia evangélica verdad
contarnos cómo era esta terapia como es
del día a día en ese tipo de lugares
pero tratas a santiago que antes hemos
pasado que también cuando me
descubrieron pues vinieron unos pastores
de madrid que vinieron a mi casa a
valencia para hacerme supuestamente un
exorcismo algún espíritus demonios todo
eso y me pusieron horarios me tiraron
todo y luego seguidamente de eso como no
habían resultados ósea seguía siendo
gays pues mi madre me dijo que me había
mira una escuela que estaba en eeuu no
recuerdo bien en el estado que estaba
persona que la california pero bueno me
lo invento
y yo miré fotos de ese sitio y yo vi que
habían chicos con batas blancas con el
pelo rapado totalmente y me dio muy mala
impresión no se tenían cara de estar
como estar estuvieran hechos una patata
tan fatal y de madre que ahí no viva
entonces mi madre me dijo que tenía que
ir a algún sitio para solucionar esto
porque no lo puedo dejar ahí entonces me
miramos para ir a brasil fui a brasil a
curitiba en el momento es mejor para
estar tres meses o sea fue un mes
primero para un poco el portugués
y luego dos meses para hacer la escuela
pues nada más llegar allí me estaban
comparando con un pederasta me estaban
tratando con un zoofílico literalmente
me dijo la persona que estaba a mi cargo
que ser homosexual es exactamente lo
mismo que tener sexo con caballos así me
lo dijo y luego ya le disfruté un
poquito le dije que no era así porque yo
sentía que lo que sentía era amor viendo
era no era vicio
y él me dijo que le recordaba a su
hermano y luego para mi sorpresa
hablar contigo o escuchar lo que ellos
te decían voy a hacer lo que ellos
quieran o está bien en rebeldía por así
decir
estuve dos meses me fugué de la escuela
de brasil no llegué solamente fui el
primer día de escuela y luego me fui
casi los dos meses estuve casi tirado en
la calle por allí por por brasil y que
pasaba por tu mente y llegaron esos
activos que hiciera que algo estaba mal
en bus no me di cuenta cuando porque yo
cuadra jovencito me enamoré de un amigo
y lo que sentía era amor entonces cuando
me trataban de sophie lic o de pederasta
de de todo porque te mete en el saco de
todo yo leo yo sentía que lo que sentí
por ese amigo era que era amor o sea no
sentí vicio o sea yo sentía mucho cariño
y muchas muchas cosas bonitas no era
todo para todo lujuria entonces yo ahí
fue cuando empecé a revelarme un poco
porque le dije que yo no era todo eso
que me estaban diciendo que era pero
bueno ya es la terapia esa de repetirte
te dicen te dicen te dicen acertando
escucharlos ciudad como que pero bueno
yo me rebelo al final en brasil o sea no
no se digan todo
a la morgue de las secuelas no que te
dejaron estas prácticas bueno resinas y
las diferentes referencias a que
comparaban la homosexualidad con la
pederastia verdad y en este sentido has
hecho declaraciones muy fuertes no es el
día de hoy que no puedes estar con niños
y niñas
por ejemplo a mí me dejan solo en una
habitación o en los esto cerrado por un
niño o una niña y me pongo muy tenso me
pongo muy nervioso estoy tierra trágame
me quiero ir donde estoy aquí no quiero
estar y esa sensación la verdad que
bastante difícil
no soy un pedófilo no me gustan los
niños y las niñas
pero bueno es una cosa que te repiten
tantas veces que al final dices tengo
miedo no de decir imagínate que estoy
solo con un niño o una niña o algo y
dicen alguna cosa yo que sé ya es miedo
de que me acusa de tantas cosas
ahora hablando de ese miedo
tuviste intentos de suicidio a verdad no
soy sólo una víctima es un sobreviviente
rubén
en casos como el mío santiago lo normal
es la gente al chaval en las sábanas se
acaban suicidando en muchos casos y la
familia lo oculta también por porque les
da vergüenza y se descubren aragón con
el señor de sus hijos si no lo quieres
decir pero yo sí intenté suicidarme
cuando llegué de brasil porque tenía
muchísima presión por parte de mi
familia de mi iglesia nos dejaban vivir
tanto el día encima mía fue horrible esa
época y luego más tarde yo seguía
trabajando en el negocio de mis padres y
yo siempre he creído que te podría
volver a tener mi familia no porque yo
la perdí en el día que se enteraron que
yo era gay o sea yo dejé de tener a mi
madre a mi padre ya mi hermana el día
que yo que descubrieron mi
homosexualidad entonces quise retomar
eso no fuimos de vacaciones por una
parte de españa por cataluña de valència
poquito más abajo y allí pues intenté
suicidarme
ya con el 2018 ya hace tres añitos ahora
fukuda en septiembre
sí sí hace poquito y bueno ya mi madre
pues aprovechar para para meter un
poquito de cizaña allí en el
psiquiátrico
le dijo así quieran que yo era violento
que yo era agresivo que esto de suicidio
era sólo para llamar la atención que
para hacer daño a mis padres porque era
muy dijo manipulado orina g siesta y tal
y me pusieron me encerraron en el
psiquiátrico cuatro días eso estuvo
entre el cerrado 29 días creo y cuatro
días con camisa de fuerza y para que me
quitaran la camisa de fuerza tuve que
reconocer que era un hijo violento
manipulador y que todo lo que ésta hacía
era para hacer daño a mi familia
y al día de hoy pasaron solo tres años
de 2018 cuál es el estado de situación
al día de hoy
pues santiago al día de hoy desde marzo
de este año del 2021 estoy bastante bien
estoy muy bien tengo mi pareja estoy
estudiando estoy formando estoy haciendo
es como si hubiera vuelto a nacer es
como si he retomado mi vida donde la
dejé y estoy muy contento ahora
claramente lo que está en el fondo
obviamente es un discurso homofóbico o
mediante mejor dicho por parte de todas
estas personas pero también una idea
vinculada a la religión de que digamos
el demonio está dentro tuyo algo así
está en la base de estas prácticas de la
que fuiste víctima
claro claro a mí cuando cuando cuando
decía nos asociamos que me hicieron
varios no fue unos voceros bastantes era
siempre echar fuera espíritu de lujuria
espíritu de pedofilia espíritu de
el espíritu de espíritu todos los
espíritus que te puedas imaginar ahí
pues
derecha afuera y
y tienes que aguantar y realmente lo de
lo del exorcismo es difícil pero hay
muchas cosas más difíciles también
aguantar el día a día al que te esté
señalando que te acusen que te traten de
traidor es para ella me tachó de traidor
o sea es una situación es como que tu
vida se pone patas arriba y todo el
mundo puede manejarla - tu es una
situación de mucha impotencia 11 incluso
hace poco hace tan sólo tres años
tuviste que fingir ser otra persona como
en otros momentos de tu vida para tener
libertad
sí claro yo cuando estuve allí hasta que
no reconocí hasta que te lo reconocí
todo hasta que lo reconocí todo no no
pude
no pude salir de allí del psiquiátrico
ahora para ir finalizando rubén estaría
bueno si puede darle un mensaje a
jóvenes que están viviendo en contextos
de intolerancia con textos o mediante si
también violentos
pues yo sí sí sí poder un consejo amigo
de antes
perdón no están llegando unos mensajes
pero si pudiera hacer un mensaje en
medio de antes de ese momento yo lo que
le diría es que estudiarse que hiciera
una vida como pueda que aguante lo que
pueda en el momento que se pueda marchar
de casa y dejar la familia
que no aguante esas cosas que no aguante
esa presión que no puedes vivir una vida
para hacer feliz a otras personas tienes
que vivir tu vida y vivir la realidad de
lo que eres
y ser feliz rubén muchísimas gracias por
este tiempo compramos 24 ha sido un
placer realmente de llevar contigo un
abrazo muy grande gracias a ti a nuestra
audiencia y le invitamos como siempre a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación también en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom y recuerden
que pueden volver a ver también esta
entrevista en nuestra página web no se
olviden que ya estamos en las pantallas
de sus hogares las 24 horas del día con
noticias a cada hora también nuevos
programas y por supuesto más entrevistas
sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y